it's time to unveil the potential of
African Club football to the world the
Africa Super League
a new era in African football has begun
the continent's governing body Cav has
announced a brand new Africa Super
League for 24 of Africa's top teams
there will be a hundred million dollars
in prize money with the winner pocketing
11.6 million dollars nearly five times
what's an offer in the current cuff
Champions League it will succeed to
significantly uplift the quality of
African football the standards of
football at Club level but also at
National Team level because a lot of the
money 54 million dollars every year will
be going to the member associations each
member Association will be getting a
million dollars
it's hope that the project will boost
Africa's football economic fortunes
Cafe's promising sponsorship and revenue
previously unheard of which given time
could give African teams the ability to
keep their best players by matching the
huge wages in European Club football in
terms of investment exposure marketing
overall as a football club and one of
the leading football clubs in the region
we're extremely excited about this
however there has been some negative
reaction
South Africa's players union says the
project is unwalkable and could wreck
professional football in Africa
comparisons will also be drawn with the
Breakaway Super League in Europe which
launched and spectacularly failed within
a matter of days last year following a
backlash from fans
while governing body FIFA was against
Europe's super league but is backing
Africa's version
getting the chance to teams for every
team in the continent to be able to play
in this competition I think this is this
is a you know a great idea a great
vision a great project the fact that is
done within the football structure as
well and not outside is obviously
crucially important for any support that
if I can give as well so it is it is a
very exciting time
Egypt's are the most successful Club in
the CAF champions league history with 10
titles and will almost certainly be part
of the new Africa Super League
the final list of teams is yet to be
finalized but what we know is that the
teams will come from 16 different
nations with a maximum of three per
country the teams will play first in a
group competition before moving on to an
American style player formered the
Africa Super League is set to start next
year in
Augusta Al Jazeera Arusha Tanzania